- Father, please hear
our prayer for the poor.
- [Man] Thank you, Father, yes.
- We beseech you for
the disenfranchised,
the less fortunate,
and those that suffer.
Show us your will so we can
continue to do your work.
- Yes, Father.
- [Godly Voice] I have come
to answer your prayers.
Listen carefully
to my instructions.
- Hallelujah!
(heavenly music)
- [Godly Voice] I want you
to sell everything you own
and immediately begin
service to the poor.
- Just want to clarify,
to everything?
- [Godly Voice] Yes,
rid yourself of all
earthly possessions.
- Oh (beep), this
house is haunted!
(group screaming)
- It's a ghost!
Move!
- Go, go, go, go!
It's insidious!
- [Godly Voice] Ah, I
see what they did there.